[Music]
hi femi okay you're watching
a packed episode of the stream we have
three stories
in one show we'll be talking about
afghanistan and us
troops leaving by january politics
in peru where can you believe that in a
single week
peru had three presidents and a memorial
that is under the ocean of the under the
atlantic ocean
memorializing enslaved africans more on
that
in just a little bit so as you can see
there's a lot to talk about a lot to get
in
if you want to comment or talk to our
guests you will have to be quick on
youtube
but you know what to do jump into the
comment section and you too can be part
of the discussion
so we start in afghanistan when by
january 2021
2000 u.s troops would have would have
left
what could possibly be the impact of
this have a look have a listen
when the foreigners left they did not
leave equipment like weapons vehicles
and other military equipment that we
needed
we are in urgent need of heavy weapons
like artillery mortars
cannons and ammunition if we have all
these heavy artillery with us we will be
able to defend our country in a better
way
the base commander says the taliban
often attacks the base from the
mountains
day and night the base is only 11
kilometers from the border with pakistan
from where he says taliban fighters can
slip
into the area
azala it's good to have you on the
stream will you tell our stream viewers
who you are
and what you do
um hello everyone orzala neymats i am
from afghanistan
and i'm leading a research think tank in
kabul
uh i'm social scientist by training
how would we know if we were in
afghanistan that us troops a big
contingent of u.s
troops were preparing to leave what
would we notice that might be different
well as a matter of fact for the
majority of afghan population nothing
really is different
because afghans have been the main
target or main victim of this war from
younger generation to older to children
everyone is affected by this war and
in the presence of troops and the
prisons of thousands hundreds and
thousands of troops we had the same
situation so
their departure for an afghan for an
average afghan
is not going to change the story however
the presence of the international
military forces
is a balancing force within the region
it gives afghanistan a level of
uh per se authority uh
in comparison to its nuclear nuclear
neighbors like pakistan like iran or
like
india and so forth so i'm just looking
at this headline here and this is from
mid-november us announces plans to cut
troop levels in afghanistan iraq now
this idea of reducing the troop levels
this is not new
but the idea of doing it literally
moments before there's going to be a new
us
president that seems strange from the
u.s
side from the afghanistan side
how do you unpack that
well the way we see it as afghans is
like this
uh uh the military intervention in
afghanistan in 2001 was related to the
elections back then
to the u.s elections the military
withdrawal
uh particularly the u.s withdrawal from
afghanistan
again 19 or 20 years on it's again
related to the
american elections so we understand that
there has been a rush
there has been a sort of a pressure uh
by taxpayers by those
families of the soldiers of why our
children our sons or
daughters are going to be killed there
and we understand that but with a such
massive level of
investment made on afghanistan to just
pack and leave is not a responsible
kind of arrangement and relations with
the country so
we mostly advocate for responsible
withdrawal where
at least some basic arrangements could
be uh could be
in place uh like the interview you have
shown
uh what worries us as afghans
is a chaos and we are old enough
unfortunately being from the war
generation to remember that 90s when the
soviets have left afghanistan we
fall into a civil war or a regional war
and we can see that now if
that such kind of withdrawals is not
done in a responsible way in a gradual
way in a way that it enables the afghan
state to stand on its own feet
it can cause and fall us back and push
us back to the same
horrors of the past it's another story
that caught my eye
and uh on al jazeera excuse me on our
zero.com we framed it as
an alarming pattern second afghan
journalist killed in a week this is
elias daily
he was a radio journalist he was an
international radio journalist
and we also caught some video of the and
i'm just going to warn you because this
is
really disturbing he was killed in a car
bomb so you see the destroyed car
and then you hear from monica's
relatives talking about his
assassination let's have a listen
[Applause]
we tried to break the vehicle's door to
get day he out of his car
and after trying for a while we managed
to get him out of the car
he was alive then he died of his wounds
when we took him to the emergency
hospital
if you pay attention to news out of
afghanistan you will see
instances of violence like this all of
the time is there an
uptick though or has something changed
or is that something that you would
expect to see that journalists
are being blown up
unfortunately uh in the most recent
in the month of november elias day was
the second
journalist and since he was
killed and assassinated in hillman
province
in kabul we had another incident
involving another
journalist either mysteriously killed or
died of
something like an incidental so
unfortunately
the civilian casualties is on the rise
despite the u.s taliban deal in february
this year
we haven't seen any changes this year
has been full of stories
some of these stories are going viral
like this young
afghan student similar to the
journalists that you have mentioned
a young student in his early twenties
hardly
remember reminding everyone not to
forget to smile
uh despite all the challenges and
problems that we are facing and this
young man
lost his uh his name was muhammad raheed
he lost his life in
in kabul university attack we have girls
we have a sister and brother who were
sitting and having breakfast they didn't
even
they were not even out of their house
just sitting unaware of
the world's ending for them in that
moment they were having breakfast in the
morning and they both
graduates of university were were
unfortunately
uh killed in a rocket uh attack so
violence is becoming part of everyday
life in afghanistan there is a zero
level trust
in terms of you know who is going to
save you who is going to protect you
there are assassinations targeting you
know uh
um young students
journalists are the prime targets
civilians and
particularly for example the aid workers
community the religious
scholars so we see three forms of target
attacks
being organized lately against people
who are active in the media against
religious scholars because there is a
fear of uh
from moderate islam that
a majority of afghans are following it
and also there is
fear of women's rights and human rights
and
the human rights category is another one
a young
um and a very talented girl named fatima
khalil
uh lost her life uh uh in a in another
magnetic ied attack uh a few months ago
uh she was just simply working uh
as a human rights activist as a human
rights officer in a
in the commission of human rights so
when we see these kind of targets
sadly uh these are all signs of things
not
not changing in a good direction we see
more violence
despite the fact that everyone is
rhetorically speaking
about peace but uh the realities are
peace
the the the the annual uh reports from
unama
uh the human uh on on on civilian
casualties is also highlighting that
31 percentage uh 31
of the casualties are comprising
of children 13 of women so women and
children
are also not safe from this violence in
a violence that is very hard to me as an
afghan who was born in afghanistan lived
most of my life
as an afghan in afghanistan or as a
refugee war refugee
i find it very difficult to explain to
the future generation
what this water is about who are we
fighting and for what reason
and yet every day sadly we are losing
lives
ozala i have some questions for you in
youtube and people
are curious because almost i think
sometimes
there is this fatigue from people
hearing about
afghanistan uh in terms of the news it's
almost like they don't
hear it they don't see it anymore
because there's so much violence and
conflict
and i want to share some of these
thoughts with you and i'm really okay
if you do disagree vehemently so amanda
iran asks is there going to be a
transitional process how are the troops
going to hand over power
to the afghan army what is the plan
process for removing troops so how is
this going to happen how do you have
2 000 u.s troops leave the country
is there a value in security what
happens
exactly this is what we are fearing uh
there are 2
500 troops that are planned to remain
uh to be withdrawn from afghanistan
in addition to the u.s troops there is
also a nato
uh base in afghanistan in kabul at least
the resolute supports and they have a
very clear mandate of training and
mentoring
the afghan national security forces but
the nato forces the resolute support
which is also
uh troops from different countries who
have been allies of the us
if u.s troops would draw logistically
and in terms of you know supplies uh
this
particular base that is supporting uh
providing capacity building supports to
our military forces in afghanistan
they will not be able to survive within
the absence of the
u.s troops this is why we have seen the
news that the
uh general secretary of nato is inviting
uh president-elect uh
joe biden to nato to collectively make a
decision on how to arrange this
exec unfortunately the way media is
portraying it
probably this was because of the
election season in the united states
it is like troops withdrawal and that's
it zero boots on the ground
uh if you ask me as an afghan i'm more
happy more than happy to actually hear
that
if troops zero troops on the ground is
going to end violence in my country
it's going to end suicide bombings
assassinations
raids bombardments of civilians
that is happening as well why would i
not celebrate it i will be the first one
to celebrate it but the reality
is way more complicated and that is that
we
as a weak state are a prime victim
of regional and global conflicts
countries fight their wars over the
lives of afghans young and old are
targeted and we just
desire and seek the assistance of people
around the world
to to ask their governments to pay
attention and to help us
in this meaningless uh violence in
conflict
there was something that you want to do
and this is almost the hardest question
to ask you
ozala and this was we could talk
for an entire show about the terrible
things that happen
in afghanistan and we would never talk
about
the stories of joy and hope
and everyday life that never gets to
they never get mentioned
so i have i have two
minutes i bet this will be the two
minutes our audience will remember if
you tell us the right story
what story do you want to tell us that
takes us away from
troops and transitions and violence and
car bombs
and tells us what it is like to live in
afghanistan
when there is hope and joy
this is actually i was going to end with
you know
there is violence there is horror that
we are experiencing but let's remember
something that a martial a young martial
muhammad raheed has told us
inside in spite of all these challenges
let's not
uh forget the smiling and this is what
our cricket players are giving us
a joy and a smile on our faces we have
the best cricket team in the world
uh some of the best players are there
and they are
literally like coming out of ashes
afghanistan
has a group of girls of orchestra
afghanistan is rising in the field of
technology we have
young girls from from herod's province
mostly
working in the technology technology
parts the robotic girls
there is a massive investment oh i love
those girls
yes i i would love to have you haven't
seen them oh my god i hope you will have
them one day they are amazing and
they're
working on programming so i would love
to have
mine you're invited girls if you're
watching you're invited
fantastic i can't wait to see them on a
stream giving that story
and their story on itself is giving this
message to those who are still believing
to
use terrorism and violence as a weapon
you are wrong try to invest on
you know happiness try to invest on
better things rather than killing people
because look
we've been killed left and right our
youngest are dying but
the the classmates the friends of those
are not surrendering
so that's the story of afghanistan now
and we hope to see it changed
rosalie thank you so much for talking to
us about the uf
afghanistan troop withdrawal what life
is like in afghanistan and some
political analysis
and some happiness all in the same time
we really appreciate you thank you very
much indeed
thanks being on the stream today my
pleasure so my pleasure thank you i
thank you
you're so welcome i'm going to take you
from afghanistan
to peru where in a single week
peru has had three presidents
young people are taken to the streets
they are asking for reform
earlier we spoke to martin and this is
what he told us
with the election of francisco sagasti
as transitory president of peru
young people expect total reforms
returning to what came before
does not seem to be an option for the
bicentennial generation
a good percentage of them demand a
change of constitution especially the
economic chapter
they also suggest a police restructuring
and above all
a frontal and aggressive fight against
corruption that has greatly harms the
country
hello pal it's really good to have you
on the stream welcome
tell everybody who you are and what you
do
one more time yes yeah that the audio
was missing
but we saw you but we did not hear you
so i will do that one more time hello
pal
great to have you on the stream tell
everybody who you are
and what you do hello hello i am
investigative journalist and i the
spanish
is i'm the correspondent of the spanish
newspapers
in peru and i am i am a writer too
it's so good to have you you have been
doing your job
so many years and i am just wondering if
you've ever seen
it like three presidents in a week
how would you explain that to the
international community
to our stream viewers what is going on
in peru right now
well it's really difficult to to
explain to uh international audience
uh when you have to when you have so
many
very very an economy very strong
but in politics never never we saw
so mess up we have three presidents
on a week but in the
since 2016 we have four persons
because since pedro pablo kuczynski
became a president we have four
presidents
and this and the economy it was
very strong we have a lot of we don't
have inflation
so for for nobody can understand
what happened in in that in that country
that kind of country so i think we have
a big crack
on 2017 when the
the i think it's like a crack
no a big crack when the old raging
and the new regime clash
because the leaders that always have
control
in the judiciary systems and the
prosecutor's office
doesn't have the power anymore because
la vajatto
is a massive a massive case of bride
from brazilian company called otterberg
exposed all the leaders all the leaders
keiko fukimori alan garcia
pero paulo kuczynski and all the leaders
that has the power
to to leave
behind all the accusations
hasn't the power anymore so this that
crash opens a new peru
because we the young people
doesn't expect nothing but a real fight
against corruption so the president
martin biscarra who was the successful
successor of
kuczynski smelled
the moment and and support
all the work for uh to the
la bajato cases when he do that
all the political uh that
he they seen they he he they were with
with him
they wants to wants to
suck from the power that's when all
that one all started so biscara has
in the power two two years and eight
months
only and when he was
uh when he was outed a and lost an
impeachment
in congress the the protest
arrived in lima but erupt in
all the country because the people
recognize
that they don't do because against the
corruption
they they recognize that they want to
they want to to they want to
have the new they all regime to stay
like that
when viscara says he would he would not
challenge
the decision but
to be a president
the the streets the the peruvians to the
streets to voice their their anger
anger yes
you're talking about the protesters on
the street i want to bring in a
protester's voice into this conversation
uh and this was tested was in lima in
peru
and he was talking about how this
movement was started by the young people
and it was invigorating older people
so this is what he said a couple of days
ago
there is corruption in the government in
congress and in the municipalities
that is why we march we are going to
insist that this great mobilization that
the youth started and which they've
offered their lives for
continues and we municipal workers also
demand a new constitution
so pal i'm just going to wrap up with
you because you sent us some beautiful
pictures and i'm going to get you just
very briefly
to describe the pictures to me is that
okay so have a hit have a look here on
my laptop
and uh
officer yesterday pacia camargo is the
brother
of inti camaro who was killed by the
policemen
during the protests in lima he
he was he received like 11
11 ballots on his body
and yesterday they rebuilt
all the scenes and how he dies
and and they they the brother
has recovered all the time all the
videos from the
from the moment that his brother died
so it was it was a moment very very
emotive because yeah brian emotional
of course yes this is uh in t camargo
and brian pintado
has the two students students who was
killed
were killed by the policemen in peru in
lima right
so pal thank you so much i
i really appreciate you people you
brought photography analysis
from peru and we really appreciate that
thank you
we're going to wrap up yes
yeah yeah i'm going to wrap up and say
thank you very much for being on the
stream today
there's always more to talk about and we
would love to have you back another time
pal thank you very much for helping us
understand
the politics in peru so we go from
peru to a virtual memorial
underneath the atlantic sea well that is
the proposal
a group of academics were looking at the
transatlantic slave trade and thinking
how do we memorialize
enslaved africans this is what they told
us
enslaved african people experienced
unimaginable conditions and extreme
violence whilst aboard slave ships
this led to the death of more than 1.8
million
africans as they crossed the atlantic
ocean
the dead and the dying were thrown
overboard cast into the ocean with the
atlantic seabed becoming their final
resting place
the seabed authority maintains maps of
mineral resources
and contracts mining contracts our
proposal is that these maps include
virtual
ribbons of the major slave-traded roots
to serve as an abiding
reminder of past injustice and of our
need to continue
pursuit of justice
so here's this is the story the group
urges atlantic seafloor to be labeled a
memorial to slave trading
just going to scoot up here so you can
see it we will post this story
and hopefully we'll be able to get a
guest on about the story very soon
uh but that gives you an idea of what
will be happening underneath the
atlantic oceans
on maps so people really understand and
appreciate
where uh slave ships were actually
people were actually drowned
and were taking on that atlantic passage
from
africa across towards the americas one
more thing to do you and that is to do
is to remind you that
instagram live happens sunday through
wednesday at 20 30 gmt
always a great conversation there even
more relaxing on the stream
and it's always good to see you that is
today's episode of the stream thanks for
joining me i'll see you next time
you